hey olivia why do you think you connect
with queen so much
i think honestly this isn't really that
deep of an answer but i genuinely just
love their music and i love jamming out
to their songs it's some of the most
iconic music to date so
that's my answer
did you guys talk a little bit about
finishing at the top of the leaderboard
tonight and how exciting that must be
i don't know how that happened i'm so
excited uh that was a first of many
tonight of tens top of the leaderboards
very wait i didn't mean to say first of
many i meant that's so wrong i meant to
just say my first you know we had a
great night you had a great night
you you stay humble i'ma celebrate her
for her i'm very proud of her she worked
really hard i was very tough on her
this week especially and quick step is
not a flattering dance for a lady
and she really yeah she really met the
challenge and
i'm excited to have
to kind of to see her i've had nights
like this long long time ago but i've
had them uh it's nice to see her
experience her first kind of ten and
that like feeling of owning the night i
think it was really special
val we saw that obviously during like
you said you were a bit tough on her and
you guys had such a challenging routine
this week and so impressive did the
tough love work is that something that
you like respond well to olivia like is
that kind of something that worked for
you guys
we're done with the tough luck
no i'm just kidding i mean i get it it's
it's really really intense and we're
coming towards the end and we both
really want to be here and so you know
it's like also we've been dancing for so
long so i get the frustration too like
there are certain things i should
probably pick up on a little bit faster
than i do but he is very patient for the
most part and you know there's also a
lot that happens that's not in the
packages of him being an absolute
sweetheart so it's it's a balance
um so we are one one step closer to the
finale um which means you know another
heartbreaking elimination tonight but
olivia can you tell me a little bit
about how
you've grown throughout this entire
experience and what this experience has
meant to you
oh my gosh this experience genuinely
means so much to me i just really feel
like i found myself in a different way i
feel like i've also just it's just a
great i think opportunity for me to kind
of
show just a different independent side
of myself and just show who i am at my
core so i'm really really grateful for
this journey just as a whole
bonus i get to learn how to dance and i
love to dance so
yeah it's just been amazing i couldn't i
really couldn't be happier with just
being on the show and saying yes to it
because i was a little nervous before we
started
uh do you guys have a reaction to the
shocking um
uh bottom two tonight what was sort of
what went through your mind when you
heard it
i was just really shocked and
i think that we're at the point in this
competition where everybody deserves to
be here you really put in so much work
and so it's really really upsetting to
see the miz go like i really adore him
and i thought he was awesome and yeah i
don't think either of them deserve to be
in the bottom two
yeah i mean obviously i have
a relationship with
what are the bottom twos
so from that sense it was uh it was you
know it was it was hard to watch
but also
the miz i mean i i
i saw the miz in the finals to be honest
like just two weeks ago i think he is a
perfect candidate for what the show is
about you know someone that embraced ev
every every detail of it
i mean just in terms of his costumes
like that alone you know his commitment
facial expressions um
yeah i mean mike's energy is what the
show is all about and so i definitely
i hated to see him down there i hated
him
i hated seeing him so defeated because
again you know jojo and jenna obviously
don't belong in the bottom two and
it's almost kind of you know it was a
given that mike was going to go when he
saw himself down there
olivia you talked about your connection
to
queen but what about janet jackson who's
coming up next week
i'm really excited for janet jackson
week i
feel like i grew up listening to more
queen but
that is not to knock down miss janet
jackson herself she is so talented
singing dancing the whole nine so
yeah hopefully we
do her justice we celebrate she's such
an icon and so i'm very excited
uh have you guys ever been in the finals
together and how do you feel about being
in the finals together
possibly this season
that's the goal
with uh jenna no we have not i have not
been in the finals with uh
my wife
yet
hopefully this will be the first time
we'll get we'll get that done we only
have time for one more question everyone
together
when it comes to uh
you dancing every week you get
celebrities that uh seem to enjoy your
your uh
dancing ability and vote for you there's
one celebrity that's had your back
uh even before dancing with the stars
and that's howard stern what are your
thoughts on his uh support of you
hey i'll take any support i can get
thank you howard stern i'm
a fan and i'm very grateful that he has
my back i think that's super super nice
of him so if for some reason howard
stern sees this come on my podcast
please
let's hang out
howard stern i listen by the way i
listened to howard stern as a young man
listening to 92.3 k rock i think in new
york city while listening to him in the
morning
that's my man
and his movie what is it private parts
is it private parts yeah one of the best
continues
every day on australia he continues to
talk about you guys hey we didn't even
know this what does he say i gotta i got
a chance to be on his show once with
rumor and he was a big fan of rumor and
he's a big fan of the show and so
and have us on your show
we won that season
howard stern is manifesting our cern is
kind of like the groundhog
you